Okay, so
the one weird thing about my kitchen is
there's no actual overhead light.
That's a really crappy one that I bought from Amazon that you have to,
like, plug in and then LCD,
and I fucking hate it. So the solution I got are these little things,
because this is the darkest little corner,
so I got these things and I just stuck them under here.
They just clip on like that
and they turn on. I don't really give a shit that their motion sensor.
I just wanna be able to see in my goddamn kitchen.
And so then they just snap in,
and now it goes from being dark to having, like,
so much extra light. Like,
look at the difference. Watch.
Hold on, let me put it here. We can see.
Watch the difference.
Okay. Dark.
They're linked right here.
If you have a dark little corner that you need to fix,